did that tell you what i saw at least i
i think i i think it was him i actually
i i 100 i think it was 100 yeah who is
it jean-claude van damme
where uh how could you not get on the
show what if we don't always say that
alex gone but
jean-claude van damme i want my ass
kicked
i've seen bloodsport yeah right he was
firing that man
uh he lives in marina he knows miranda
he lives by china
he was i knew was him does what does his
hair look like right now can we see this
i don't know because
i want it i want to make sure it was him
because i i think it was
but uh he he's drawing some badass
bentley
really i mean he's still i'm sure he's
crushing it in life still
he has to be he had a documentary i
think he was on show time
uh jay junk jcvd
and it was uh this a pretty dope dope uh
documentary
he's talking about his coke problems
[ __ ] like that
is this what he looks like right now it
should be 12 hours ago okay
yeah then i can't see the hair
oh did his hair look good or no
yeah but definitely a toupee dog
have you ever seen one take the head off
you ever seen when he was at there's a
reason why he's wearing a hat
um although i wear hats that's an old
picture april 18th
yeah that's an old picture he's covering
it anyways yeah i i 100 think it was him
you didn't say nothing to him no what do
you want to say to him
i don't know i don't know i mean like
you know what like it's one of those
things with him like i was just like
i'll let that man be
because i'm pretty sure he probably gets
stopped a lot that's probably the way to
go you know what i mean there's certain
people worried about talking about old
school [ __ ] blood sport reference
yeah what am i what
am i going to say to him like man i
[ __ ] loved you in bloodsport i've
never seen
more yeah i've seen blood sport more
than any movie i've ever seen
in this entire world maybe i'd rather
watch it [ __ ] you oh yeah we've watched
on the road
oh yeah every character me and my
brother watch that movie every day after
school
probably three years straight nonstop we
know everybody
so then we grew up in venice in the
summers we're at gold's gym
and uh chung lee was at gold's gym and
my brother's like holy [ __ ]
you know trouble
yeah yeah yeah he's bs that dude yeah
he's [ __ ] dope you break my record
yeah i break you
he's gonna he's been in bruce lee films
too yeah he
i think he still looks great so we saw
my gold
he's short but he's [ __ ] swole and we
were kids we were probably like nine
i was probably nine my brother's like 11
and we see my brother's like oh [ __ ]
there's jung lee i'm like oh [ __ ] we're
freaking out this is our movie
and my brother goes up to i i just don't
think he speaks english very well
but we didn't know that we're kids my
brother goes oh what's up chun li
but and he goes and like brushes off
because off he's in the middle of his
workout yeah
and my brother was so offended he goes
man i'm glad jean-claude van damme
kicked your ass
i was like what's wrong with you dog
what the [ __ ] that's like the worst
thing
jay was a little baby
man meanwhile he could have [ __ ] all
up he could've my dad was there yeah i
think he yeah he still looks great
he's uh what bruce lee film was he in
enter the dragon
inner dragon was that one yeah he's old
school man he is dude oh they got a
badass mural of him
he was jacked too and he's chinese right
chin young
what's his young yeah what's his real
name
bolo young oh it's polo
how do you say it young chinese american
40
so wait chinese american 74 years old
bodybuilder born
in straight up china god he was great
why are they dual nationality chinese
american you probably got
citizenship maybe oh that's is that what
that means his english wasn't good but
we didn't know those kids
and it really pissed jay off oh yeah
he's
not happy he was like i was like
jean-claude kicked your ass i was like
yeah i mean that's a move even i was
again he got his homie's bandana back
was it a bandana or something
they've been friends for eight days any
time
anywhere oh is that what he says
anywhere
because i love you love you brother and
then they grab hands i'm like you guys
have known each other for eight days
wait doesn't he get with the blonde
chick at the end
no he gets with her during the movie
remember he's in his undies doing split
after he
nutted all of it she's like reporter and
they hook up
in the hotel and then she wakes up and
she's like well she's all out of here
what and then he's just [ __ ] in the
room and just switch yeah he's whitey
tighties which is why i still wear
whitey ties this day
and he's doing the splits and she's like
what the [ __ ] do you think she's still
hot
oh i don't know she probably is
father time son of a [ __ ] no people not
there's some people that dude i still i
still wish you would have
uh asked john claude to be our third
host you imagined i couldn't i couldn't
go
i don't know there's certain people that
i'm like i'll leave them alone that's
either gonna be dope or to be a
nightmare he just keeps talking about
old school stories about being on set up
[ __ ]
blood sport or junk or cyborg or some
[ __ ] look oh she looks great
that was around the movie right yeah
that's what yeah that's right that's
after that
yeah she looks great yeah she's still
yeah she looks great yeah
foxy yeah she was such a diamond in that
movie
mm-hmm that og curly hair that big dude
picks her up
he's like trying to [ __ ] her and then
and then john
in that bar it didn't make sense though
because it was like an asian dude but he
had a turban on it's very strange
turban and then remember john clyde gets
the quarter out and then he makes it
disappear
and then he puts in his hand oh yeah
yeah he's like if i take it you leave
her alone he's like
deal he marries english
and i guess they were betting to [ __ ]
the girl
hey that's like that's what they did
back in the 80s man that's the 80s i
i listen that is frowned upon don't do
it now
no christian don't do anything like that
now come on dog frowned upon
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together do
bro come on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son